sir gregory p winter was born 1951 in
leicester united kingdom he got his PhD
1976 at the University of Cambridge
the first Cambridge and he's now a
research leader emeritus at the MRC
Laboratory of Molecular Biology in
Cambridge he realized early on that face
display could become a very useful
method when you work with antibodies
this would be a tool to derive their
high affinity antibodies for any targets
that you wish with strong determination
he spent all the effort required to make
it possible to display antibodies or
antibody fragments in functional form on
the surface or the filamentous phage so
that he couldn't fish out the good
members from libraries sir Gregory
winter I now welcome you on stage thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
well good morning ladies and gentlemen
it's still just the morning Sara thank
you for your introduction may also thank
you and your colleagues on the chemistry
committee and their advisers for all the
hard work they had to do that ended up
with this with me getting a share in
this prize so thanks um I would first
like to acknowledge and thank my family
it gives me great pleasure they're all
here today and we'll have to listen to
me for a whole half an hour without
interrupting me or saying dad we didn't
want a lecture on it so I would also
like to thank the academic institutions
that I our dear
this is going to stop messing about to
thank the various academic institutions
who've supported me throughout my
scientific life in particular the MRC
the Medical Research Council's
laboratory of molecular biology in
Cambridge the Medical Research Council
scent of a protein engineering in
Cambridge and Trinity College Cambridge
all the same Cambridge's I would also
like to acknowledge the key role of a
startup company Cambridge antibody
technology fourth time I've mentioned
Cambridge in the work that I'm going to
describe I'd also like to thank some
individuals
I hope they recognize themselves from
some years back I'd particularly like to
thank John McCafferty who was the first
to show the display of functional
antibody fragments on phage I'd also
like to thank Alan first for his hand in
a number of things but particularly when
he was director of the Centre for
protein engineering for accommodating
the greater part of my group as it was
developing the phage technology
and all the others on the slide who are
probably the most important because they
did the work they did the work at
different times they all had key roles
and they are the anonymous we that I
shall refer to during the talk finally I
would like to acknowledge Richard Lerner
and his group at the Scripps Research
Institute although we were certainly the
scientific competitors at that time
their activities complemented our own
and actually confirmed our own faith in
our work it actually helped us persevere
through many technical difficulties
because if we we knew that if we didn't
manage to do it they would so first of
all you had a tutorial on phages I'm now
going to give you a tutorial on
antibodies um
antibodies are part of our immune
defense system they defend us against
infectious agents such as viruses and
bacteria they're raised by the immune
system in response to infection or
vaccination an IgG antibody as shown on
this slide is a large y-shaped molecule
it's got two arms and a stem it
comprises two heavy and two light chains
of linked protein domains in this case
it's the white and the red the heavy and
light chain variable domains which are
at the end of the arms come together to
form a protein scaffold of beta sheet
which I've marked here um that
surmounted by six loops these are these
red loops numbered 1 to 6 which are
responsible for binding to the antigen
and in binding to the antigen they can
block the process of infection in
addition the antibodies stem here is
able to recruit the immune system to
kill the infectious agent to which it's
attached now the variability of these
antigen binding loops is created through
rearrangement of different germline
segments of DNA during B cell
development in heavy chains it's created
through random combinations of three
segments the so-called VH D and J
segments as marked on the slide each of
which has multiple members so you get
tremendous combinatorial diversity by
throwing these germ line segments
together in the light chain it's created
by random combination of two sets of
gene segments in addition where they
join there's editing takes place and
further diversity can occur during
during the DNA rearrangement process as
well as random pairing between the heavy
and light chain domains as the heavier
light chains are rearranged
independently so after DNA rearrangement
each B cell which I've got here so this
is before rearrangement after
rearrangement it encodes a unique
antibody on its surface so the
rearrangement process leads to
expression or antibody on the surface of
the B cell as the DNA rearrangements
proceeding in parallel and independently
in many B cells
this creates a library of B cells each
with a different antibody on its surface
if the displayed antibody encounters an
antigen the B cell is stimulated to
differentiate and it can do two things
it can differentiate to become a plasma
cell which essentially is a factory for
production of soluble antibody against
the cognate antigen that that antibody
is recognized alternatively it can
become a memory cell as mock here where
it where the antibody genes are
subjected to random mutation within the
cell on further encounter with the
antigen the memory b-cells compete for
antigen and those displaying mutant
antibodies which have got the highest
binding affinity a favored for further
rounds of differentiation
this leads to an antibody response that
improves with with a real simulation
with with antigen it's a process known
as affinity maturation so in summary the
immune system is a simple evolutionary
system at its heart is the b-cell
it's a phenotype a genotype a firmly
linked it's a censored you netic display
package with the antibody displayed on
the outside of the cell to encounter
antigen and the genes encoding the
antibody within now although nature
developed antibodies to protect against
infectious disease man has further
developed and evolved them for the
treatment of non infectious disease such
as inflammatory disorders and cancer
man-made antibodies can be used for
example to block the biology of protein
receptors and ligands such as they're
involved in inflammatory disorders or
cell growth or even t-cell activation or
they can be used to kill target cells by
recruiting the immune system to attack
it's the development of antibodies for
treatment of non infectious disease
that's revolutionized the pharmaceutical
industry and what this slide shows is
the is the top selling drugs in 2016
previously the pharmaceutical industry
was dominated by chemicals but what we
can see here I marked in red in among
those top ten those antibody products so
actually the pharmaceutical industry in
the top selling products is now
dominated by antibodies we've got six
antibodies and the number one antibody
is an antibody called Humira which I'll
come back to later these antibodies are
mainly used for treatment of autoimmune
inflammatory diseases and cancer
the the technologies to make such
antibody pharmaceuticals required
several years of inventions and
developments it started with the
invention of hybridomas by Saddam
Milstein actually also at the MRC
laboratory of molecular biology in
Cambridge in 1995 they immunize mice
with target antigens such as human
cancer cells the spleens were harvested
and the responding b-cells were
immortalized by a cell fusion the hybrid
cells or hybridomas were then screened
to identify those making monoclonal
antibodies against the target antigens
although this technology generated many
useful research reagents against human
proteins and cells the mouse monoclonal
antibodies was seen as foreign and when
injected into patients they this
compromised the use in fact it would
leave two life-threatening reactions at
that time and he but attempts to make
human monoclonal antibodies against
cancer cells proved impossible not least
because the immune system has tolerance
mechanisms that prevent it making
antibodies against self-generate this is
fortunate where these mechanisms break
down it generates terrible autoimmune
disease by the mid-1990s solutions for
making antibody therapeutics began to
emerge through the application of
protein engineering this is a branch of
genetic engineering which the genes of a
protein are altered and the encoded
proteins are expressed in a host cell
the first solutions here involved
creating a map it creating what we call
simple chimeric antibodies in which we
take the entire antigen binding regions
at the end of the mouse monoclonal
antibody that for example could be
against a cancer cell and we transplant
the entire region into a human
antibodies the human antibody is marked
white so this antibody is two-thirds
human one-third Mouse and should
therefore perhaps be better tolerated
when put into patient
it's then came humanized antibodies down
here in which the antigen binding loops
were grafted from the mouse scaffold the
speeder sheet scaffold with the six
loops were grafted from the scaffold to
its human counterpart
now as the inventors of humanized
antibodies which are up to 95 percent
human origin we argued that such
antibodies might in practice be regarded
as synthetic human antibodies as in any
case these loop regions differ between
one human antibody to the next
experience has actually borne this out
humanized antibodies are well tolerated
in the clinic and account for the
majority of antibody pharmaceuticals on
the market but at the time we weren't
actually so sure that the human immune
system wouldn't somehow sniff out the
taint of mouse that's in those loops and
it might treat them as foreign you know
I have a so very anthropomorphic view of
molecules I think you need to think
about them like that
and I was very I was very uneasy about
it despite my logical arguments that
they were just the same as human
antibodies so we were very receptive to
an opportunity to make fully human
antibodies that emerged from a technical
advance one of the the rate-limiting
steps in making chimeric antibodies
these are the 1/3 human 2/3 Mouse was
the isolation from the hybridomas of the
genes encoding the antibody variable
regions in theory this is
straightforward in practice actually
it's it's a pain in the neck and to
simplify matters we thought we might be
able to use the polymerase chain
reaction to amplify and clone the genes
from the hybridomas now in the
polymerase chain reaction target regions
of DNA so except one here can be
amplified by repeated cycles of
extension of two flanking primers by DNA
polymerase and by repeating the cycles
one
get a dramatic amplification of that DNA
and clone it but since we didn't know
what the sequences of the genes were in
any particular hybridoma it wasn't clear
that we could design PCR primers that
would work on any hybridoma what we did
was to compare lots of different
antibody sequences and we spotted
regions at the ends of so if we look
here this is a heavy chains heavy chain
sequences we look at nucleotide
conservation at the end we could see
regions which are a hundred percent
conserved with Rick with with regions
where they're not conserved and we
thought that maybe by playing around
with experimental conditions we might be
able to find a set of PCR primers that
could amplify any Mouse V gene from
hybridoma so we set ourselves that task
involved a lot of fiddling about it was
the early days of PCR but in fact we we
did find a set of primers that worked
for most hybridomas we could actually
amplify the genes from most hybridomas
we were given and we later developed a
similar set of PCR primers for
amplifying human antibody genes now
these primers made it so much easier to
clone antibody v genes and it and this
it is that that presented the new
opportunities for example instead of
isolating the mouse v genes from
antibodies take from hybridomas why not
amplify them directly from the spleen of
an immunized Mouse if we express the
encoded antibodies perhaps we could find
the ones with antigen binding activities
this offered a simple alternative to
hybridoma technology for making mouse
monoclonal antibodies but better still
if we could make libraries of human
antibodies we might be able to bypass
immunization and find ones with binding
activities to human self antigens as we
need for therapeutic use so we were
excited by the potential but first we
had to find an expression host
we looked at bacteria it had recently
been shown that function antibody
fragments could be expressed in the
bacterial periplasm we took libraries of
antibody fragments from welts we took we
took libraries of antibody genes and
expressed these as fragments in bacteria
those genes came from immunized mice and
we soon discovered fragments with
antigen binding activity now by this
time we'd become aware of a similar
approach being explored by the group of
Richard Lerner at the Scripps Research
Institute who had similar results but
both of our groups were completely
unable to detect antigen binding without
the use of immunization so clearly our
our screening methods weren't really
powerful enough certainly if we wanted
to make human antibodies we therefore
look back at how the immune system
manages to select antibodies as I
explained earlier at its heart is the
b-cell could we find a b-cell mimic we
thought of many possibilities display on
mammalian cells display on bacteria or
even display on bacterial viruses but it
looked like I would need some more staff
but I didn't have the money or the space
to accommodate them at that time I met
David chisel and John McAfee from a
mushroom international who due to an
error in the counting processes were in
the process of being made redundant they
were excited about the possibility any
job really they were excited about the
possibility but they were particularly
Explorer excited by the potential of the
library technology and we wondered about
forming a startup company to do that but
it was a struggle to get funding but
finally I succeeded to an old friend
Jeffrey Grigg he'd set up a star he'd
set up a startup company peptic in
Australia that was mainly backed by the
mums and dads of Australia but it also
seemed he backed by a I would call the
horse racing fraternity I had to go and
meet the shareholders on a yacht in
Sydney Harbour and I remember one of
them saying I'll give Greg the money
let's see how the boffin trots
which was so peptic in fact in the end
became the major shareholder in
Cambridge antibody technology
David chisel and John McCafferty joined
and John came to work in the laboratory
of molecular biology and we decided to
focus our energies on the beast you've
heard about in the previous talk
the filamentous bacteria phage so some
four years earlier George Smith had
shown that filamentous bacteria phage
was capable of displaying peptides and
that the phages display barring the
peptide epitopes on the phage gene
through protein could be selected by
binding to cognate antibodies so could
this phage serve as our mimic of the B
cell instead of peptides could we
display folded antibody fragments on the
phage and in this slide I've actually
used a different representation of phage
this is what I call our Dalek
representation which I much prefer to
the very long phages this is like
something out of Doctor Who and we
rather liked it so we've been using this
very simplified representation so what
we have here is the antibody genes on
the inside of the phage and the the
antibodies the antibody fragments
so-called single trained efi fragments
where we have a linked heavy and light
chain variable domain on the outside
they're fused to the phage through the
gene 3 protein so then we tested the
recombinant phage for binding to the the
hen egg white lysosome which was the
antibody corresponding to these V genes
we've taken a monoclonal antibody
hybridoma and we cloned it in here and
we found out these phage is using
analyzer assay bound very selectively
and specifically to hen egg white
lysozyme but not for example to turkey
lysis AIIMS they're very specific and it
everything we looked very good so we now
mix the phage antibody with a large
excess of wild-type phage and attempted
to enrich the phage antibody to show the
demonstrate to the other work of George
Smith and and Parmelee the affinity
selection process and we found that we
could select this phage by multiple
rounds of affinity columns
in fact on one pass we could enrich the
phage or antibody phage a thousandfold
and by growing the enriched phage and
passing it down the column a second time
we can enrich it a further thousandfold
which means we've got a millionfold
enrichment over two rounds of selection
and in principle using three rounds of
selection you could get a billion-fold
then you could go up to George's
gazillion if you just increase the
number of of cycles so we were very
pleased really that these folded
fragments could express on phage because
it certainly wasn't clear to us that
they would but it turned out to be
that's what the system seemed to work
beautifully
so we then turned to making antibody
expression libraries are on phage and
the the library was a so-called random
combinatorial library it was a type that
had been described earlier by the
Scripps group in which a library of
antibody heavy chains is combined
directly with a library of light chains
usually from the same immunization and
this process so for it this process can
be expected to generate the original
heavy light chain combinations of the
b-cell that it originated from as well
as entirely new combinations and this is
shown on this slide so let's take a very
simple case of two B cells with encoding
two different antibodies one with a red
and white light chain and the other one
sorry one with a red heavy chain and a
white light chain and the other one with
a green heavy chain and a black light
chain so if we clone out those genes and
we shuffle them all up we end up getting
four possible combinations two of the
original and two new ones the red blacks
and the green whites now as you increase
the number of b-cells that you that you
use you you decrease the probability of
finding the original combination and you
increase the probability of finding new
combinations so for example if you took
a thousand b-cells in principle which
were all different in principle you get
a million different combinations by
combining them of which a thousand would
be the originals and 999 thousand would
be would be new combos
so we were very interested in you combos
because actually in if we were to take
antibody genes from humans we need we
knew we needed to generate new
combinations of heavy and light to
generate new binding activities in order
to be able to I to find things in there
that would bind to the self antigens we
knew the immune system would have
deleted all of those original
combinations that bound to the self
antigen so for our first library we took
the V genes from the spleen of a mouse
immunized with a hapten a phenol phenol
oxidize alone now you may wonder what a
hapten is it's essentially just a
chemical entity that's coupled to a
protein and it's been used by
immunologists for many years just to
study how the immune system works and it
simplifies the the understanding of of
of how the immune system works and the
kind of antibodies that you get to
different to different targets now from
a library of about a million clones we
obtained faint binders with a range of
different heavy and light chain pairs
and we couldn't distinguish the original
from the new ones but some had binding
affinities comparable to the very best
hybridomas in other words in the order
of 10 nano molar these were hybridomas
made by says our Milstein from that same
spleen because we ran the thing in
parallel we cut the spear in half he had
one but we did the other the affinities
he could get were as good as the ones
that we could get which was a great
irritation to him um but the technology
was looking very promising with our
second library we faced up to the
altogether more difficult problem of
making human monoclonal antibodies
without immunization after actually
quite a few technical improvements I
didn't have time to go into we created a
a larger and more diverse library this
time from the white cells of human blood
donors from a library of 10 million
phage clone senses tenfold bigger than
that one I've described earlier from the
immune Mouse we managed to isolate
binders to many different antigens
foreign antigens human self antigens
and but these had binding affinities in
the micromolar range and those
affinities are too poor to use for
therapeutic use so we knew we got to
improve those affinities so I'm just
going to focus on the left-hand side of
the slide we decided to improve those
finishers let's follow what the immune
system does so the immune system takes
selected b-cell clones and it subjects
them to random mutation and further
rounds of selection with antigen so for
example we took a a phenol oxygen
binding phage antibody from our human
library with a rather modest micromolar
affinity and we grew it in a bacterial
mutator strain and after multiple rounds
of growth and selection an increasingly
stringent selection we managed to get
mutants crawling out at the end with
affinities a hundredfold greater now in
the low nano molar range which is quite
comparable to the affinities of mouse
monoclonal antibodies made by repeated
immunizations of the same antigen in a
mouse we could even construct a
genealogical tree and we've got some
some attempt to show this here in which
you could see the sequences that we by
sequencing all the mutants that we've
got at different rounds we could
identify four sequentially acquired
mutations each of which was responsible
for lifting up the affinity and giving
us this this this great increase in
binding affinity the right-hand side of
the slide describes a shuffling approach
which I'm not going to go into but it's
an alternative and simpler way of
creating faster way of creating affinity
improvements but it's not enough for it
wasn't enough just simply to create
mutations we also needed to find ways of
selecting between between those stages
with different binding affinities and to
do this we applied increasingly
stringent affinity selection so for
example using longer wash times so all
the weak binders washed off and the
strong binder stayed stuck to the
support the other possibility was use
low concentrations of antigen so here
what I've shown here is on the left is
we've biotinylated the antigen
let it equilibrate with the phage and
then captured the phage bound to the
antigen using streptavidin beads and
that also showed that we could in with
this we could apply that and fish out
selectively those phages with the higher
binding activity but there was a
confounding issue which is touched on
here and that is um that we discovered
we hadn't really expected this
whereas in George's case that the phage
generally it all the antibody heads
express a peptide but in the case of the
antibodies we found that a lot of our
antibody heads were chewed off so a
phage antibody might have between 1 & 5
heads each species actually presenting
different binding of visitors to a solid
support which greatly complicated our
selection of those with the highest
binding affinity so we reduce this
problem by a an approach devised by Jim
wells in which what he did was he I
think he died for a slightly different
purpose in which we created what so
called monomeric phage with fewer
antibody heads so actually what we end
up doing is is infecting us right we
encode the antibody fusion on a so
called phage mitt and we use a helper
phage to supply the other gene 3
subunits so we end up with antibodies
which have a single antibody on there or
otherwise they're completely bald now
the bald ones don't bind to anything so
that's very easy so you just end up with
those which are bearing the antibody so
as well as developing libraries of V
genes from these B lymphocytes we also
have been exploring the creation of
synthetic V gene libraries by cut by
combination of the underlying V gene
segments building blocks now the
advantage of synthetic antibodies is
that the diversity of the library is
known and it we can tune it to order but
at that time the sequences of most of
the human V genes were not were not
known and if we wanted to use those as
building blocks we had to
find them so we started mapping and
systematically cloning and sequencing
all of the human build antibody building
blocks and then we assembled them to
create our largest and most diverse
phage library of more than 10 billion
clones including almost all of the human
B gene segments so we now got a huge
library and we could select that so we
assembled the library these featured
segments as indicated on the left and
then we selected that library and
against foreign and self antigens and we
now found antibodies with binding
affinities in the nano molar range quite
comparable to the finishes of hybridomas
it in fact really by using these very
large libraries we avoided the need to
do so much affinity maturation so the
great thing about this is from a single
very large library you could fish out
antibodies to all kinds of different
targets now in parallel with our work at
the MRC the startup company Cambridge
antibody was working with commercial
partners to develop human therapeutic
antibodies the most spectacular success
was the development of the phage
antibody a dilemma map which is
otherwise known as Humira which is
targeted against TNF alpha an
inflammatory mediator and it's used for
treatment of autoimmune inflammatory
diseases such as rheumatoid arthritis
psoriasis or Crohn's disease now when we
started the work on a dilemma map the
random comet or a light with the random
comment or libraries of human antibodies
just weren't large or diverse enough we
couldn't find anything in there that
would be useful so we had to try a
different strategy and we decided we
would we would try and bootstrap
starting with a mouse antibody so we
have a mouse antibody which I've marked
in red and we took this for example here
the mountain sorry the mouse heavy chain
variable region we paired it with a
library of human light chain so you
up with this hybrids a half human half
mouse we're selecting on antigen and we
did in fact find we got some binders by
doing that and now now what we did was
we combined that selected human chain
here with its partner chains from from a
human library and essentially selected
again so in a couple of steps we'd
managed to create a a human antibody
essentially from a mouse template so I
wouldn't call it a humanized antibodies
no trace of mouse in there other than we
have built this human antibody using
this Mouse template so it's essentially
rather like the sole grandfather Zacks
business you know the handle you know
that right my grandfather changed the
head and and my father changed that
their handle and you know it's my
grandfather's axe well you know it's
completely different the whole thing is
completely different is a different
entity altogether now other than a
dilemma map Cambridge antibody
technology and late later MedImmune into
which it was incorporated a focused on
creating very large libraries usually
not synthetic but from human donors of
about 100 billion clones and they end up
getting high affinity antibodies from
those and I'm grateful to Janos born of
MedImmune who used to work in Cambridge
antibody before they were taken over for
the information on this slide so the
upper portion shows the range of
pharmaceutical target classes including
targets here which which MedImmune has
made phage antibodies to and you could
see a whole range of growth factors
chemokines ion channels receptors gpcrs
cytokines protease inhibitors and
peptides and on the lower portion of
this slide down here you can see those
phage antibodies that are already on the
market so they've gone through the whole
process of clinical trials and testing
and there there are 60 more still in
clinical trial are still moving through
the system
and so in conclusion you can see that
this technology's antibody repertoires
with the filamentous phage has actually
proved extremely powerful way of
harnessing evolution and is delivering a
great new wave of antibody medicines
with that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]